[Music]
Ian thanks for joining us I know you're
busy let me start with Gary uncon Lee of
Ohio State I know he's not going to go
to the draft he's being investigated
what can you tell us about this
situation of a guy defensive back who
was going to be a first-round draft pick
yeah I was slated to be likely a top 15
draft pick and now poised to lose
millions tens of millions of dollars so
a couple things are going on now the
police in Cleveland are investigating
he's slated to me with them after the
draft to give his side of the story so
that's one thing as police try to get
together had not been charged they're
still looking into this that is one part
of it the other part of these teams are
now investigating and saying what do we
actually know and I notice because some
teams have been calling me and saying
what do you know because it's just
they're playing beat the clock right now
they got 48 hours or so a little less to
try to figure out is just someone who is
a first-round pick someone who we take a
risk on a third round so Lee's draftable
at all
you know this kind of reminds me of the
Lyle Collins situation couple years ago
was a person of interest in a murder
investigation ended up being completely
cleared but still was not drafted and
ended up signing with the Cowboys it's
just I don't know if there's enough time
for teams to figure this out to come to
some sort of conclusion where they could
know what his fate is going to be can he
do an interview holder press contantly
and what advice would you give him you
know given the fact the time timing of
the draft yeah it's it's tough to know
what the right answer and what the right
course of action for him is until you
know to what level he was actually
involved and how much merit there is to
what police are discussing you know if
and you know I've talked to general
managers about this I start to coaches
about this because they want to know
what he's going to do to you know I
would expect more information to come
out today on him there are some witness
statements that end up clearing him you
know some there's at least one that does
not clear
there's a couple that do clear him in
the eyes of these witnesses I would
expect some of those to come out today
and maybe change the public discourse
maybe not
but but you know it is it is difficult
to unring that Bell because at this
point and owners are involved they want
to know how safe is this person on
picking and for a team to pick this guy
would have to be very very confident as
Jabril peppers cost himself some money
he has uh and from Laos here and you
know I I know some people talk about him
as a first-round pick that was not quite
in line with what I was hearing for me
it was early second maybe mid second so
I think that's probably where he ends up
going you know maybe mid to late second
and it's not you know the diluted test
is is one thing kind of similar story he
gave that Reuben foster gave so that's
one part of it the other part of it is
he's a great athlete I mean I was a
great college player they don't know
what position he's going to play she's
strong safety is he a slot is he a free
is he running back so I think this sort
of lack of you know versatility is good
but lack of knowing what position he
plays causes him to be more of a second
rounder I was talking to Ian Rapoport
NFL Network insider I know that we get
fascinated with number one and with the
Browns on the clock there's reason to be
fascinated San Francisco to me nobody's
talking about the Niners that it feels
like oh they're taking Solomon Thomas
and I'm not so sure here in or am I you
know in a minority no I'm not so sure
either they're considering you know a
couple different things and they have
clamped down pretty good as far as
letting people know who they're taking
and you know they could broadcast it
because we basically know he's going one
they could tell us who's going to and
really wind affect things but that's
really not how they do business anymore
so they've kind of clamped down but you
know Salomon Thomas is a very good
player I know they're considering it too
they're also considering Leonard
fournette they're also considering a
quarterback likely mister Biscay they
they got some and I know they are
considering a move down so they got some
they got some real options there and you
know for net would be in
interesting one for me because when I
talk to evaluators about it you know
it'd be very high for running back but
man he would just kill it in cash and
hand system and that that could be an
interesting set when does the drama
happen tomorrow when the Niners are on
the clock okay you know first round I
mean there'll be some stuff free staff
teams you're talking to teams but you
know I don't expect anything with the
first dick when the Niners get on the
clock you're going to start hearing
who's trying to come up and really you
know a couple of the quarterback teams
you know bills Browns are trying to come
up but really the focus will be do the
Browns trade up into the top ten to try
to get true Biscay or do they just chill
and wait and say we're confident that no
one's going to take him before 12:00
with the judge take true Biscay if he's
there at 6:00 they like him it is an
option from what I understand I would be
a little surprised if they did they have
so many needs defensively they love this
defensive draft if OJ Howard is their
really really good tight end I they will
have to think very hard about that as
well they've had so little production
went tight in in the past I think that's
something that we'll have to look out
for - yeah the whole quarter I know we
get caught up in two quarterbacks you
know we love the skill position players
with a mock draft it's not sexy to talk
about a defensive lineman or defensive
mechanic right with that being said
where is Christian McCaffrey going to go
I would be very surprised if he's not a
top ten pick right now which is crazy
because if you told me about a month ago
I would just laugh but he's a great
player he is someone teams are
fascinated by and I would you know could
be as high as eight I mean the Carolina
Panthers have done a lot of work on them
I know they've been looking harder -
running back they well fournette I think
for that might be gone and the captain
would make a lot of sense there and you
know this is sort of a media thing I
know we're all kind of discussing the
Panthers and McCaffrey but there is a
lot there and I think that's pretty real
where were you with Laremy Tunsil
situation last
you're in the building right oh yeah I
was I would I got a text right before
the draft
who and it was like you know OMG emojis
and I'm like what God's name could
possibly be happening right now
that would cause soldiers there we go we
have an emoji for Laremy Tunsil
it was the one where you're like what we
do not have a gas-mask emoji okay I'm
surprised no one created that um it was
the oh my god face and then one of our
buddy Andrew groovers on our news test
sends me the video and was like you need
to see this and so you know that's one
of those things like art the situation
just changed this is out there this is
going to be the story of the draft so I
started making calls and I think by 7th
or so pick we were able to go on TV and
say this is Tunsil it was two years ago
teams are looking into it you know kind
of like that but but that situation the
Connelly situation you know you prepare
so much for this draft and then we just
never know what's going to happen
Marshawn Lynch no reader expected to be
by the end of the day if everything goes
well he you will be and you know he's
flying back from Haiti it's he was
supposed to fly back yesterday and
didn't get on a plane expected to be
back today take a physical and yeah I
mean after you know months and weeks of
talking about it he's got a deal you
know going to pay him three million
dollars could pay them up to aid with
the Raiders for this year the Seahawks
and Raiders have agreed on a trade you
know unless Lynch just doesn't show up
which I'm told that's not going to
happen he will be a Raider and this
whole thing will finally have a
conclusion
hey thanks for joining us I know you're
busy and have fun tomorrow night awesome
will do thanks for having I that's Ian
Rapoport the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience